[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000.
my name is caleb denby and i will be
your driver on this journey
uh tonight i wanted to go over yet
another one or two of my games this time
from the bill wright st louis open that
actually just took place uh right here
at the chess club uh it was an exciting
event um there were some huge twists in
the final round i was actually in joint
first going into the last round and then
both myself and the other leader lost in
the last round and ended up sharing
second place instead of first place uh
so sad ending to to a fun tournament but
i wanted to go over one or two of those
games here because i felt that there was
a quite a bit to learn from
so
to start with i actually want to go over
this game that i played against vinnie
toddy parthi so he has been coming to
the chess club for quite a few years
here uh he's around 1900 and i wanted to
take a look at some of the mistakes he's
making at that 1900 level that uh made
this game uh not not quite go his way
so jumping into it here the game started
with d4 d5
c4 e6
knight c3 so so far a normal queen's
gambit declines and then uh vinnie chose
to play this move c5 so are you familiar
with this move c5 has anyone seen c5
before
yep steven um
vinnie's 1900 uscf or so sometimes he's
a bit more sometimes a bit less i don't
think he's ever crossed 2000 though
c5 looks familiar so what is c5 all
about maybe you can tell me what is
black trying to do with this move c5 any
idiots
yeah so he's basically doing what white
was doing in the opening right whites
plays c4 to try to trade off the c pawn
for his center pawn and give himself or
give yourself a central majority uh so
black is responding very much in kind as
quickly and directly as possible
and as someone in the chat points out
this is actually called the the terrash
one of the openings named after terrash
so it seems like this opening has a lot
of upsides for black right you know
there's no
waiting around in a qgd where you're
gonna end up going
c6 first and only c5 later maybe or
there's no allowing for a minority
attack in a normal carl's badge
structure
instead what black is going for is uh
immediate trades in the center and
immediate ways to to try and equalize
so if white isn't careful if white just
plays sort of normal looking moves like
knight f3
let's say knight c6 and e3
let's say knight f6
and like bishop b2 or something you
might find yourself
in a position
where
black has gotten a favorable iqp right
black immediately trades off those c
pawns and d pawns gives white this
isolated queen pawn and in this
particular instance it's gonna have a
good setup against it right he can maybe
play knight before at some point bring
this knight to d5 just a good solid
setup against an iqp for black so that's
the dream for black but unfortunately
c5 comes at a cost which is black is a
little bit underdeveloped and since
black hasn't developed much
uh it's going to be tough to keep track
of everything going on in the center
here right so
to start with i took on d5
we got e takes d5 and then i did just
respond with knight to f3
and now rather than white being left
with the iqp if black tries to take on
d4 we just take back and this is going
to be a very very good iqp position for
white
because
number one we have two pieces developed
and black has none uh number two we're
already well blockading the pawn
attacking the pawn we're in good
position to maybe even go g3 add more
attackers to this pawn and black is
gonna have to really babysit this guy
for for a while
uh so instead black plays knight f6 sort
of anticipating this kind of structure
but structure by uh defending this pawn
a little bit more closely
then there's a few ways that you can
develop out here uh knight f6 is
actually not the most common move i
think because this moved bishop g5 might
be very very strong instead normally
they go knight c6 here not allowing you
to pin the knight
i was out of theory though so i just
stuck with some normal looking moves
and i played this move e3 here so what
do you guys think about this move e3
normally
someone might try to tell you that this
move is incorrect
so
you know why is that what's going on
here
it feels like it traps the dark square
bishop
right this is the principle that we
learn when we're you know first learning
openings especially in queens pawn
openings you want to get your bishop
outside the pawn chain so e3 is is very
much locking this bishop inside the pawn
chain
and everybody gets an amber alert okay
um
i it's going off in my pocket too
okay e3 locking this bishop inside the
pawn chain
um
which is normally not ideal right
normally you want this bishop out here
on f4 on g5 somewhere more active right
uh but in this case
i play e3 anyways so why why did we
break the rule here why why are we
allowed to block our bishop in
and i'm going to ask you this question
uh and i want you to think about it with
this pawn on c5 versus this pawn on c6
what's different why are we okay with
blocking this bishop in depending on
where this pawn is
okay bishop b4 so that's not quite right
not quite right
um in fact if we were worried about
bishop b4 it's handy to have this bishop
back here right it could potentially you
know block defense and dark squares
whereas okay let's say the pawn is on c6
and we're worried about bishop b4
then bishop b4 would be more of a
problem if a bishop were outside the
pawn chain on f4 with it on c1 it could
help defend the dark squares
so so not quite good idea though it's
important to like look at the
differences
yeah so e3 does some or does some good
things as the chat is pointing out it
defends d4 it opens up the light squared
bishop but the question is why
play e3 now why not play it after like
bishop g5 or something which is
maybe even the best move in this case
so the difference that i want to point
out is that with this pawn on c6 there's
no clear plan to activate white's dark
square bishop right with the pawn on c6
no matter where you put your dark
squared bishop it's not really going to
get active unless you get like f3 e4
which is pretty hard to achieve here
right
whereas with the pawn on c5 we are
pretty much always going to have this
option to play d take c5
so i'm okay with blocking in my bishop
with e3 because i have a clear plan to
activate my dark squared bishop now what
is that plan well i want to go b3 bishop
b2 and take on c5 allowing my bishop to
c on this open diagonal and the bishop's
actually going to be really well placed
here right it's guarding the square in
front of a potentially isolated d-pawn
it's on a long open diagonal
and it's going to be hard to
oppose hard to attack
so with this pawn on c5 it makes a lot
more sense to play e3 than with the pawn
on c6 because we have this clear plan to
activate our bishop anyways
um so why do i spend so much time on
this well it's important to point out
when you break an opening principle it's
important that you have a very distinct
and clear reason for it you need a clear
plan to activate your pieces if you're
going to do something like like e3
so that's the difference i was i was
fishing for something to keep in mind
how can you change the structure how can
you activate your pieces uh depending on
what your opponent has chosen to do
okay benny continues with knight to c6
now we're very much very much back in in
normal territory i just continue with
bishop to e2
um and i choose e2 over d3 here because
the fight for the d4 square is sort of
on and i don't really want to get pinned
with bishop g4 i want my knight to be
able to defend here my queen to be able
to see this pawn as well
uh black chooses bishop e7 just
developing i castle black castles and of
course i continue out with with b3
so so far so normal right we just uh
have developed our pieces gotten castled
and are getting ready to play uh the
moves that we were planning to play
uh now black plays h6 so what do you
guys think about this move of h6
good idea bad idea
so there's two conflicting chat messages
in in the twitch chat one says uh some
left is good sometimes so just saying
you know h6 it seems like a fine move
gives the king left also you know
defends the g5 square nothing can ever
land there uh seems like you know
overall probably a positive uh change to
black's position and then the next chat
message says i think it wasted tempo and
someone else says isn't h6 a wasted time
so that's the question can black afford
to waste time here with something like
h6 now whether or not it's a waste is up
for debate
but um
is it the kind of position where black
can take a tempo play a move like h6
or did black have to play
more quickly
so
yeah you think it's it's fine right i
mean it's not like uh h6 is
creating horrible weaknesses or anything
right i mean you can argue it weakens
the light squares slightly not not a big
deal in my opinion
um
but the fact of the matter is black has
actually played a very combative opening
right uh we have tension in the center
things can change in the center black
has already uh weakened some central
pawns
and when you do that with the black
pieces you have to play very quickly
very uh uh quickly and with a sense of
urgency because if you do this if you
make these pawns sort of vulnerable
early on and then you start spending
time on moves like h6 moves that could
have been spent developing
developing your bishop for example or
defending your center with something
like b6
um then things are gonna start to drop
because
uh and you know i mean you're allowed to
play combatively like this with black
but you have to be aware that you're
running some serious risks if you do
right white gets the first move white is
going to be the first one to uh
start targeting these pieces so h6 is
way too slow for an opening like the
terrace
now again if you imagine this knight on
d7 and this pawn on c6 very similar
looking position
now in that position i think h6 would be
would be fine i still think it's a
little bit slow
we might be better spent uh
we might be better off spending our time
playing something like rookie eight but
i think h6 would be fine there there's
no tension in the center all white's
going to do is try and get the pieces on
a normal looking squares
so you can afford to move like h6 but
with the pawn on c5 things are in
tension in the center there's pressure
on d5 pressure on c5 you really can't be
spending time on moves like h6
okay
so i just go bishop b2 you don't need to
try and refute your opponent's opening
just because they played one slow move
you just want to play normal chess and
then you'll have a good position
um black plays bishop to f5 and i think
this is also a little bit of a mistake
here
um f5 seems like a very active diagonal
but it turns out this bishop needs to be
better spent uh needs to be
spent uh
helping the center supporting the center
here again black has made a lot of
weaknesses in the center and this bishop
on f5 while it's active doesn't actually
help defend any of these these
weaknesses or advance blacks black's
play really
so i think better squares are e6 or g4
here these would both be normal squares
so why e6 well it's not hard to to
understand you want to defend your east
your d5 pawn and this move actually kind
of justifies h6 right you want to stop
knight g5 so you can play bishop e6 help
defend your center
bishop g4 is pretty similar we want to
maybe target d4 maybe prevent this
knight from uh
blockading a future isolated d-pawn so
bishop g4 very normal now bishop f5 on
the other hand
this is uh you know only the second
really weird move by black but already
black is in pretty deep trouble
uh so it's white to move here see if you
can apply a lot of pressure to black's
position
we want to ratchet up the pressure
pressure
so again we're thinking about ways
to target this center
plaque has extended very far
oh lots of ideas
i love it i love it when there's lots of
ideas in the chat
what are we thinking in person audience
what are we thinking
um this night
yeah 95
is what you're thinking
yeah okay
that's one
any other moves spring to mind
so i want to say here white's position
is already really good so a lot of the
normal looking moves are going to be
quite strong but i like the move played
in the game a bit better than the other
ones
right so dc5 i mean you should always be
thinking about the the potential capture
in the position right uh on every turn
when there's tension in the center you
need to be thinking what happens if i
take my opponent and if you don't take
your opponent what happens if they take
me next turn you want to be looking at
that change in structure on every turn
for sure
um so
one or two more ideas i want to see
thrown out there before we move on any
other ideas
from the in-person
audience
yeah okay so bishop d3 offering a trade
of the bishops or
maybe we can activate these guys right
maybe rook c1
right so rook c1 is what i chose in the
game and i'll go into why
um so 95 is a pretty reasonable move in
a position like this
um
but i'm not sure it really helps us that
much right black uh i don't i don't know
what we're we're trying to threaten with
knight e5
now a move like d take c5 i'm gonna
freely admit here i think that white is
much better in this position
um you know this d-pawn is going to be
weak we have good control over d4 we can
maybe reroute our knight to help
blockade this pawn
and white's going to be better
now that being said let's say i pass
and black takes on d4
i think that white is even more better
if black takes us
and it's not like if i don't take this
pawn it's gonna be able to run away
so my thinking was why would i you know
capture my opponent if it's better for
me if my opponent captures me right i'm
gonna have this option later
and if black has to capture me then
great i get to activate my pieces
all right does it make sense how
you know while this is good for white
we have activated our opponent's bishop
versus this position
where our opponent has activated our own
knight and if one more trait happens all
of a sudden you start to get a little
bit afraid of what's happening on on
this diagonal
um
so that's why i didn't want to go for
dtake c5 now again i think dc5 is is
probably very good for white as as are
many things
now the moves that really stuck out to
me here are knight a4 and rook c1
and
these are the kind of moves that can be
really powerful when
you have tension in the center
when pieces are in tension and it's good
for you if your opponent takes it's
really nice to like i said ratchet up
the pressure add more attackers to those
pieces and tension to sort of force your
opponent's hand force them to blink
first and be the one to relieve the
tension
um
so between knight a4 and rook c1 i liked
rook c1 better because this knight's
already doing something and this rook is
not doing anything on a1 you always want
to bring in more pieces
so rook c1 is is my choice
my opponent sort of smelled the danger
here uh if you don't do anything
then i am going to actually play knight
a4 and you will be forced to capture on
d4 again giving me that good position
that i was looking for
uh so he tried b6 trying to defend the
pawn with another pawn um preparing if i
capture probably not to take back with
the bishop but instead to take back with
the pawn and get this hanging pawn
structure where he's battling back for
these central squares
um now these positions are are their own
sort of animal so i don't want to go
into those just yet
but the point is here white is is
already um
close to uh to winning i think close to
winning so white to move
and continue to amp up that pressure
what's next
okay the chat's spotting some strikes
bishop
yeah this should be five okay you're
spotting the same threats as the chat
um so bishop b5 hits this knight right
and then the other idea in the chat is
again to go knight a4 or this idea that
i didn't mention was also brought up a
bishop a3
so between these three ideas
which of these is the most useful for us
which one follows
follows our our previous play the best
also well thank you for the raid uh
zefcat i don't
actually see that in the
chat program that i'm using but that's
okay
thank you thank you we're talking about
the the trash tarash tonight talking
about this game
in the tarash
so one of these moves is
far better than the other two
is it 984 it is knight a4 so why why
knight a4 over these these other options
well it's obviously part of our plan
because we were considering it last turn
um
discovers roxy5
right it number one it increases the
pressure on c5 exactly what we wanted to
do we wanted to ramp up the pressure
force our opponent into doing something
with this pawn
number two it opens up both our bishop
and our rook now this is why it's better
than bishop a3 because our bishop is
already well placed here it's on this
long diagonal again a long diagonal that
we intend to open up at some point
um
so we don't really want to move it again
to a3 whereas our knight it's now being
very very useful in
ratcheting up the tension with these two
pawns that's that's what it's about in
this opening we want to make something
happen here
um now why is bishop e5 a bad move
why why is this one no good
yeah maybe the rook right so bishop b5
looks like it gains a tempo against the
knight but actually rook c8 is a very
helpful move for our opponent right it
defends the knight and beyond that it
indirectly helps defend the c5 pawn so
this is sort of the opposite of what we
wanted
not only is it not increasing the
tension against the pawn on c5 it's
helping our opponent uh preemptively
sort of defend against our ideas
so it's an you know it's nice to look
for tempo moves like bishop b5 but you
have to play them with a purpose right
we're not playing knight a4 because it
makes the threat we're playing knight a4
because it makes a threat that works
with our plan
and also tactically knight a4 is sort of
just winning
so knight a4 and let's let's do a quick
count here so i've got three attackers
and you only have two defenders on on
your c5 pawn
and unfortunately for black it turns out
to be very very difficult to defend this
pawn again
queen d6 isn't actually a real defender
because the queen sort of blocks off the
bishop
really quickly do you guys see the
problem with knight to d7
quick tactics puzzle rush
okay maybe it's not quite
as puzzle rush as i had hoped
yeah so d takes c5 right
and we discover the threat against uh
the d5 pawn
and capture this pawn but now our
opponent can i guess just go knight take
c5
and defend this one
but again we are achieving
a very favorable uh iqp here this this
d-pawn in fact is is probably gonna fall
without uh too much more of a fight
if i can play some example moves here
maybe maybe i'll embarrass myself maybe
i won't but knight back to c3 might be
quite strong
i think you have to play bishop e6 if
you go knight b4 actually maybe you can
just play knight before all right hold
on i have to be careful here i have to
be careful
oh let's see what what to do in this
position what to do
maybe i cheat let's cheat
okay yeah knight c3 and knight c5 are
both good knight b4 is not a problem
because we just go knight d4 or queen d4
okay it all makes sense and you never go
bishop f6 because knight is hanging and
you never go night here because i take
and take
and you're in big trouble big big
trouble
so knight c5 no good so knight d7 not
gonna do it
um queen d6 like i said not going to do
it and what happens on knight to e4
can you come up with any good move after
knight to e4 so the knight of course is
defending this pawn on c5
so we amped up the pressure and our
opponent ramped up the
defense now how do we continue again
we're playing very concretely we have
our idea we want to increase pressure on
c5 make our opponent do something with
this pawn
how do we keep playing in that same vein
how do we keep it going
so this piece is well placed this piece
is well placed
and even this bishop is well placed
right you got to be a little bit careful
about this bishop bishop a3
there might even be tactics that you
have to look out for where one takes
pawn might be discovering a threat
so i'm going to give you a hint here not
bishop a3 our bishop is well placed on
this diagonal
so what other pieces can we get involved
yep so
we're looking at these these minor
pieces right these are the ones
that are maybe feeling just a little bit
left out
yeah so bishop d3 is a great idea so
what is what is the point what are you
trying to do
yeah exactly right you're trying to
remove this defender of the pawn on c5
this knight is defending it's what's is
pretty much the last piece in our way
before we can just win a pawn on c5 so
you want to get rid of the knight
um so that's the good idea in general
but now let's look at the specifics
let's say
black plays some move like bishop back
to
g6
uh now specifically if you try to follow
through with your plan play bishop takes
knight
uh unfortunately after pawn takes bishop
i think you actually just have
you lose a tempo here right your knight
gets attacked you have to move the
knight again
and after knight here maybe now black
has a tempo to try and save something
maybe we go knight before
and things start to get a little bit
awkward on your d3 square
so there's some way that we can do the
same idea of attacking the knight
without losing that tempo that critical
tempo
yeah knight d2 is great
not only does it remove this knight
preemptively from this pawn that would
be attacking it
uh but
we're usually a little bit happier about
trading off our knight for another night
rather than one of our bishops right
this is our quote-unquote good bishop
it's uh it might not look like it's
contributing much to this c5 business
but it's still a good piece it's on
active open diagonals
but knight d2 in the game is very direct
very straightforward and i think it's
correct here uh you just
attack the defender and now this pawn on
c5 is is
more or less dead
um i think
the computer says you have to play
something like bishop f6 here and try to
stay in the game like this but i think
you do still lose uh end up losing
losing a pawn
let's see what happens let's see if i
take
and take
let's just try taking everything
at the end of the day your c5 pawn is is
still going to fall right
um you can try takes again i'm just
going to take
so bishop f6 still not going to be good
enough that was the computer's best try
now if you go bishop d6 it's what my
opponent did in the game
we're just going to do the exact same
thing finally we can just break through
we take off the defender
we take on c5 and take on c5
and
now our our opponent is in a very very
bad way
in a very bad way
ah and quick question from the chat
which is good to point out i sort of
glossed over this they're asking uh so
this knight on f3 was useful to defend
the d4 pawn right now that we played
knight d2 can black take here
but unfortunately for black that does
leave this knight on c6 behind so again
another reason why bishop b5 might not
be so good because it induces our
opponent to play a move that would help
him defend down this c file whereas here
he has this prop this problem on on c6
already
but okay here we are in the game and i
think white is more or less totally
winning here
um i think maybe what my opponent missed
is he was relying on having some sort of
attack with these bishops uh sort of
glaring down the board but unfortunately
this this kind of idea just isn't every
really gonna work right you can try some
you know glorious double bishop
sacrifice but i don't think it's going
to get you anywhere right like
i don't know check
take
but
you very quickly run out of things to do
here this bishop keeps this knight at
bay and you're attacking with just a
queen and at the very least i can block
you maybe i can even you know be a hero
and play king h3 and run you out of
checks like this
so
not gonna be good enough for black my
opponent realized it and just took on c5
uh takes back
and now this is more or less just just
totally lost so i'm gonna fast forward
through some of this game kind of show
you uh how he continued so queen c1
attacked the knight my opponent goes 95.
i go queen to c3 putting on this kind of
pressure here
f6 just rip to d1
putting pressure on d5
and then things very quickly sort of
crumble for my opponent rook to d8
but now i actually have this nice little
uh tactic to win the d5 pawn go f3 f4
drive my opponent's pieces back and then
i can actually just uh take on d5 sorry
for all the arrows
the point being that you get two rooks
for the queen if you take on d5 back
uh but at the very end i go bishop f3
and i'm actually winning an exchange so
would be winning material if you took on
d5
instead my opponent went back to e7
we traded and here i am just up two
pawns
and yeah the chat says resignable
clearly you know a player of my caliber
would never mess up such a winning
position with two bishops
uh but vinnie is nothing if if not very
resilient and very uh very tough to keep
down um
i'm
quite fortunate that i often get good
positions against him in the opening
because if i didn't i get the feeling uh
my results might not be quite as
convincing as as they have been
so i'm not going to show you how things
uh
i'm not going to show you everything
here we're going to skip forward a
little bit but there is actually a
moment in this game where vinnie could
have saved save the position so i'll
quickly sort of zoom through
uh so after you know i did all the hard
work i i felt like i won everything i
quickly played queen to d4 which is kind
of just a blunder just allows this move
queen to a5 when these two things are
being threatened
and you know i i wasn't sweating it too
much i can give this a pawn back without
really spoiling anything so i just go
king f2
you know vinnie comes after me though
queen a2
i defense and attack we get queen b1
we do some shuffling with the checks
queen comes back to b1
and then i go bishop e6 so there are
some kind of nasty tactics here
if you really try to do anything
um let's just say you pass with h5
uh the idea here was actually
to play this knight this nice move f5
and the point is if you capture i can
actually give check taking advantage of
the pin
and to take the knight and then you're
you're basically checkmated here if you
check me i can always come back and i'm
just up a piece
so facing this thread of f5 vinnie went
bishop d3
now i just uh improved my king with king
to g3 stepping out of the second ranked
checks
you get queen to f1
and now quick question for you guys
should i go queen to e1 trading queens
or should i do something else something
that keeps the queens on maybe
uh maybe e4 for example uh trying to go
for this queen d8 check again
or if not e4 maybe just a simple move
like h3 like let's say h3
so should i trade queens or should i not
trade queens here
with my v shop pair
yep that's exactly right so
uh you know people talk about how strong
the bishop pair is and uh it might not
be quite as well known they actually are
even more dominant in the end game in my
opinion they they're very very good in
the end game it's very tough to play
against the bishop pair in the end game
they cover just huge
swans of the board
and
uh
tough to play against so queen e1
definitely uh the simplest the most
practical move and i think just just the
best move so this queen is actually
trapped so we have to trade
now my opponent goes about the process
of untangling this knight
we get the check and bishop d5 and you
can already see like every square in
black's position is getting attacked by
these these bishops not not a6 but the
rest of these
um my opponent goes a6
i go king to f3 opponent goes f5 and
then i realize i can make a past pawn
here so i go ahead and do so g4 g6 take
take e4
and here my opponent says okay i'll go
into this bishop versus knight end game
so
i saw this coming and i thought that
this one would be pretty easy to win
turns out it kind of is but there's a
little bit of a danger here and the
danger is that i did kind of trade a lot
of pawns to get here right i only have
three pawns left
and in minor piece end games
if you trade too many pawns then
eventually your opponent is just going
to sacrifice the remaining piece for
your last pawn and it's going to be a
draw because you can't just checkmate
with the bishop right
so that was the danger here
and vinnie
uh managed to manage to get me to to
mess this up so he goes 96 which is a
bad move he was in a little bit of time
pressure i just go bishop back to e3 now
vinnie actually does have to return back
to d8
if you don't otherwise f5 becomes very
good with the bishop attacking the pawn
on h6
so he comes back and
plays h5 so he doesn't lose this pawn
he goes knight f7
and i bring my king towards the king
side here
f6 king f5
he goes h4 trying to draw my king away
from my f6 pawn
just go bishop d4 i mean so far so good
this is
not too crazy stuff
it goes king to e6
uh and now i go bishop all the way back
to a1 because i am good enough at chess
to not hang this one
thankfully so i go bishop a1 just
getting my bishop out of the way
goes knight to e4
and
now i'm willing to say i i make a pretty
big mistake here pretty big mistake
so white to move
and avoid black's tricky idea
so black has a very nasty idea here to
try to make my life hard
and yeah it's easy to make fun of it for
his 96 night back to d8 maneuver but it
actually shows quite a lot of maturity
at the chessboard you know not not too
many people are capable of just
immediately admitting no wait i was
wrong my knight doesn't belong in e6 i'm
going back to d8 and that's actually
quite a useful skill to be able to have
just be able to say
no i i was wrong to go to e6 i
understand that d8 is the best i can do
now and just
shamelessly go back just admit your
wrongs
and
go about the business of correcting them
so someone in the chat has spotted
black's trick so how do you stop black's
black's trick
so uh christmas tronic in the chat does
have all the right ideas
so any ideas what black has up his
sleeve here this one's kind of tough i
mean i missed it
so let's say you take the pawn
right
how can black
potentially win one of our guys
one of our guys is in danger here now
it's not going to be knight f6 because
we can always trade into this end game
in this end game super super winning
right black is gonna have to deal with
this pawn in the meantime we come take
this pawn and since we don't have a rook
pawn on this side of the board it's
never even close just always wins
this pawn we're like on a3
sometimes there's crazy stuff but i
think even here that that would be would
be winning so not knight f6 but he has
some other idea in mind and i actually
took on h4 in the game
any ideas
i think the chat has it
so black wants to go after the b pawn
right but if he goes after the b pawn
right away
then we're just going to play b4 and
this is what i saw and then i was
thinking
now no matter what happens i can worst
case i can always defend my pawn if i
need to
and in the meantime i mean i'm just
going to go here and start pushing this
guy and win win without too much of a
fight
but my opponent can actually play this
nasty move a5
and then after a5
my pawn is stuck
and it turns out there's absolutely
nothing i can do to stop knight d2
knight takes b3
so of course in this position by far the
simplest way to win is to play b4 here
just not allow my opponent to play this
a5 idea
and then i you know i i'm never not
going to win three pawns on the board is
always going to be good enough here
um but instead we got this position
so i'm going to say my mistake here was
not necessarily king takes h4 my mistake
was not uh slowing down and calculating
and then to make matters worse uh after
i played king takes h4 and a i'm sorry
we just study got a little bit messed up
yeah into a5
um i still uh didn't calculate for for
long enough um i had like 20 minutes on
my clock at the very least i think so i
had time to sit down and figure this out
but instead i am
again moved a little bit too quickly and
missed a drawing idea so white to move
here is actually only one way
only one way to win
um
and if you guys at home want to try to
figure it out you're welcome to pause
here and calculate forever
i'm not going to try to make you guys
answer this for the interest of time
and also because it's it's actually
quite a difficult one
so in the game i noticed that after
knight d2 knight b3 my bishop on a1 was
attacked so i decided to play bishop to
b2 just anticipating my opponent's idea
and getting my bishop out of the threat
of capture
and now what i was thinking is you know
knight d2 i'll step to g5 king f7
you can i'll go h4
you can take me but once i got here in
my head i was like okay i mean there's
no way you're stopping this right
there's no way you're stopping this
but unfortunately it turns out you are
h5 knight c5 h6 you have the check
and then here
knight
back to f8 and shockingly
this is a fortress there's just no way
through for white i can attack your
knight and now you can come to h7 i
think you can also come to g6 amazingly
i think you go to g6
and somehow i am unable to queen any of
my pawns black is going to repeat with
knight h8 to g6 forever and ever and
ever and there's nothing that i can do
about it with white
nothing i can do about it i can i can
play
bishop f8 and you can't take but you can
just go knight back to h8 and then i'm
in trouble
and if you try this now the a pawn comes
in handy and it's actually
uh
okay wait a second
how did i achieve this
okay i go knight here first
then after queens
now it's actually white who is losing
the game
so really crazy drawing idea with that
fortress against the the f and h pawns
but
after bishop b2 vinnie actually misses
it and plays knight f2 check so after
all that he faltered at the last second
and i did end up winning the game
anyways
um but the only move to win here is to
just go king to g4
let black play this idea and then the
critical point is that we don't spend
time saving our bishop here we just go
you just go with h5
you don't have time to waste saving your
bishop otherwise this idea is going to
be good enough to draw
so you just go h5 uh knight takes here i
think we do have to defend our pawn
now if you don't go king of seven i go
king g6 and i think or nice they'll just
go h6
so for example if you try to bring the
knight back
you are nowhere close to being in time
and i queen
okay maybe i don't go to that square
actually i go to this square no i lied
which square do i go to i go to this
square and then i queen so there's no
forks
and if you go king f7 again i push
and push
try king g8 come here
and again
not going to be good enough not gonna be
good enough
so i still had a way out after a5 but i
did not find it but then my opponent
didn't punish me went knight up two
instead and then this is not so hard i
just come take this guy at the very
least i can push this guy multiple ways
to win here and vinnie ended up
resigning
so pretty tough game overall
got a huge opening advantage using these
critical ideas
of keeping the tension adding pressure
in the position that was the main
takeaway from the opening uh whenever
you have
uh pawns in tension like this like these
pawns on c5 and d4
where it's bad for either side
kind of bad for either side to capture
white can always actually just take and
be a little bit better
a really useful idea is this point of
adding tension to the pawn so rook c1
adding tension knight a4 adding tension
and then eventually black's position
just crumbles you just can't handle all
the pressure on c5
and immediately out of the opening it's
actually like plus three plus four here
uh like white is just entirely winning
uh after taking on c5
so do you guys have any questions on
this game or that kind of crazy end game
that i got featured
questions about what happened here
anything
says that was a nice game that was one
of the better ones for me of the
tournament even though i did blunder at
the very end but uh
had some fun games this tournament for
sure
okay
well with that we've got about 10
minutes left
why don't i show you a little bit of a
puzzle
from the dreaded last round
so i was playing black here and
uh i just needed again with a win in
this game i am
st louis open champion go home in glory
take the first place prize
but
uh couldn't do it so
just for a change of pace why don't we
play a little game where you try
to checkmate me
okay so we're gonna just ignore
everything that happened in this game
that's fine
so
here we have this position
uh my opponent correctly finds rook
takes d4
so now who can tell me what's wrong with
knight takes d4
any ideas
let's start with this one first little
puzzle for you this was a very very
tactical game
um and while you're thinking padalka in
the chat says is it better was it better
to not trade off the bishop for the past
pawn i mean you can definitely just play
the position with the two bishops there
um but i mean the end game with that
past pawn is pretty clearly winning um
it's just that i i messed it up so
um sort of
six in one hand half dozen in the other
both end games are totally winning i
chose to go for the one with the pass
pawn
so georgie in the chat has the crazy
idea you actually go
queen f2 here and this is what i was
relying on to save my save my skin here
i can go queen f2 get these queens off
the board
and then amazingly
in this end game i think black is just
winning
um we first go c3
now you don't have time to bring your
king back because c2 is unstoppable the
rook cannot defend
so you have to take or you have to go
rook d1 let's say you take
now i go c2
can't go to c4 um oh but you can check
actually wait a second
so maybe i don't go c3 maybe i go a3
probably i go a3 okay and let's say rook
d1
now c3 king g2
um
a2
f2
wait a second what's happening here oh
my goodness all right what what's going
on in this end game am i crazy
okay
white is completely winning in this end
game
never mind
am i losing it
okay queen e4 check apparently is a draw
here so i i hadn't actually checked this
one with the engine yet uh but i i
thought that this end game was was
actually good for black but it turns out
white is in time by a tempo it looks
like so never mind ignore all that white
played this move rook d4 which i thought
was simpler
um probably good probably good
so why rook d4 instead of knight t4 well
now there's no queen f2 because you are
stopping me right
so okay
so i go knight takes d4
um we get knight takes d4 and now of
course if i take here white's going to
go queen h6 and i'm in big big trouble
so i don't take there i go check
and g5 allowing my queen to come back
into the game
so white plays this move queen to h6
and i play this nice little tricky idea
of queen to h7
so here i actually thought that maybe i
uh i had saved myself a little bit
so what's going on here who can find
what's going on here
right to move
quan says you thought it worked i also
thought it worked
i also
surprised myself there
once i put it on the board
so yeah it's white to move and find a
very very rude way to win
very rude very mean
i just take on h7 and play f5
uh close
close so take on h7 is option number one
and take on g5 is option number two
right
so you have to decide uh which is is the
way to go here so if you take
and go f5 um i think i just take
and this end game i'm a little bit more
confident about not being so so bad for
me because now i'm only down at night
instead of a full rook and i've got my
own rook to play with and i don't think
these pawns are exactly queening right
away right
so
something a little bit more convincing
than that
yeah so queen g5
and then here's my big trick
here's my big trick so if i go queen to
g6 i agree that i think white is just
winning you just take this guy
um you can take e6
or even yeah i think you just take e6
and it's like you're just totally busted
here these pawns queen faster than
black's pawns are gonna queen
so i can't go queen g6 but what i can do
is king h8
crazy idea and then your your queen is
actually trapped
i did it i trapped your queen you go
rook h2 rook g8
and this is what i was hoping for this
is what i was hoping for actually
um
and i think if this has happened maybe
i'm not in so much trouble
maybe i don't know let's ask let's ask
i've been wrong before yeah no still
totally busted always losing always
losing turns out white is even winning
this end game but only if you find
knight c2 here tough
okay but this would have been a better
try for me than than what happened in
the game
so with that in mind not queen takes g5
but instead
what can we do
what can we do here
it's actually going to be checkmate in
like
seven moves
maximum
so no one has found the key move yeah
okay
knight c6 there you go
that's the way then
backrank you or put my rook in h2 that
way yep knight to c6
and it's just totally dead just totally
dead here with black this is
somehow like a massive mating net like i
you know i can run with my king out this
way i can run with my king out this way
but every square is just going to be
covered and i'm i'm just entirely boxed
in
and this is this is just checkmate this
is like checkmate 3. like there's
nothing to do
um in the game you know i tried giving a
check
just king g4
and now of course after takes
um just i'd like to see or sorry not
knight c6 but we can go check
knight c6 or 97
and checkmate nowhere to go
if i had tried running with my king
then amazingly knight to e7
and every square on the f file is
covered
and i have to go to the h file and no
matter where i go this is mate in one
really really tough stuff
and king g8 same story i mean you can
take the rook first of all but you can
actually just also do this um actually
no you can't i lied but you can go over
h2 here
and same story just go 97 next and it's
it's dead it's just dead
so
i got destroyed
unfortunately so nice find by the way
this knight c6 move i entirely missed it
in the game i thought my opponent was
just gonna like do something dumb like
take on g5 or something maybe play king
g4
and i was gonna like take here and it
was gonna be a fight
but no such luck just knight c6
and
nothing to do but but resign nothing to
do but resign
um so i think that's just about all i
have for you guys here today but i have
exciting news we have a brand new grand
master in residence for you guys today
uh romaine edouard who is french but
came here all the way from spain so
uh pretty fun we're happy to have him in
st louis it's the first person we've had
from overseas in quite some time
and romaine's a great a great one to
start with so hopefully you guys enjoy
his first lecture um as always i want to
thank you all very much for joining me
here tonight thank you for watching my
name is caleb denby and i will see you
guys next time
[Music]
you